we saw plenty of protests in the Streets
of London and Paris and Berlin and so on
but they
were
supporting uh uh the Palestinian cuse
but more specifically in many cases
glorifying those uh uh Hamas fighters
who who carried out that that murder now
part of that is of course this is one
particular uh episode in a broader uh
political conflict but is very
complicated and reasonable people can
have very different views about
why for example um we are so far from
peace today and that has I think led to
a lack of moral Clarity in some
journalists who want to complicate
individual episodes in this conflict um
even if those are morally absolutely
clear you can have different views about
Isel Palestine you should not be able to
have different views intellectually and
morally about the permissibility of this
uh terrible terrorist attack